[Musica]
dice che ho sempre sperato di non
trovarsi mai hai detto all'ultimo
vangelo non cercherò mai sperando sempre
di trovarti che ho risposto al momento
la riduzione speculare su sublime ma
ogni giorno che passa senza del mio
unico commento e quel commento dice tu
invece oggi voglio parlarvi di poesia
che vi convincerà che la poesia di tutto
televisione che sono creazioni che
bellezza e verità che la russia è amore
voglio che quando uscirete da qui
iniziate a compiere atti politici
voglio che quando tornerete a casa
quagliata riposto in maniera inversa
quello che quando ripensa mentale che
parole qualcosa luci nei vostri occhi
se un sul tecnico si sa a cosa ha
pensato
qual è l'immagine che proiettata nella
nostra testa probabilmente pensate a un
poema o forse al gesto di un poeta che
manca da inchiostro nero un mezzo fondi
gialli to michael hanno visioni si
veicolano missioni per gelato sia è
innanzitutto una visione conosce telaio
live è un antico componimento giapponese
nata nel xvii secolo
originariamente perché sa che significa
la strana d'esordio fu solo due secoli
più tardi che è lo scrittore giapponese
manuka shiki con questo termine aiutando
ma con tratta di all
che significa adesso di un buon
carattere scherzoso con esso il poeta ci
sta uno stato d'animo attraverso le
immagini della nato nativo circonda il
tetto se brucia ora posso vedere donna
ecco una visione
la versione di un ostacolo che è stato
superato questa è la sensazione che
volete a smettere la crisi a questo
stato d'animo temporaneo fugace ed
effimero la visione più propriamente di
un celerino orizzonte che si aprono ai
nostri oggi e di una duna che li tournée
in questo ai per questo componimento
giapponese formato da 17 more abbiamo
tanta shiori tanta tecnica
il fascino che dai versi si vada verso
il lettore andato oltre la vera parola
scritta e avvolgendo of nick invano un
vago
egli intende terminato non e compassione
ed empatia oppure traccia nel viaggio
andiamo in un altro continente andiamo
personale lampi lettere la genetica alla
magica città di buenos aires rifugio
mentale in italia che ora non esiste più
e pensiamo alle parole di un grande
poeta fosse il più grande di tutti i
cori che gli sporchi che per l'argentina
è stato tutto e che tutto andato
all'agenzia che lo scoprisse test è uno
dei tool palio a terminare alla sua
antica delle stragi del telepass della
sembra aver virato salus dispersa da uno
dei palchi aver visto le antiche stete
dalla panchina coperto dall'ombra del
rischio con le luci non tar anzi che
migliora anzi
e lì dall'ombra mi ha ordinato in
costellazione sclavi ignoranza non è
imparando a non dare ne ha ordinate in
costellazione ha vestito il simbolo
dell'acqua tra segretari per alle 16
cerchio dell'acqua nella cisterna
segreto e loro stessa e la madre serba
l'odore della madre sempre esistito del
pacato dormito il silenzio dell'uccello
che il pos e la tendenza qua e là come
tanti altri volta da umidità e sas cosa
a caso poi queste cose forse sono la
poesia
siamo infatti al primo pranzato fa caldo
cedibilità del piccolo stand ci sono dei
mori lontananze bambini giocare a
pallone non mancarono nel fosso siamo in
uno dei bar riccio anticipo nella res
sant'elmo dove a mezzanotte la domenica
sera accade la magia
perché si parla tango il passato regole
dove se provate a chiudere gli occhi
tutto può succedere
senza volerlo abbiamo scoperto un tema
comune al nostro ragionamento che sono
le emozioni perché la musica che non so
perché parlare di questi ha mai
dentemente a che fare con esso parlare
di poesia significa scavata nel nostro
cuore zuccherificio che l'ha sepolta c è
la letargo parla di qualsiasi lista
dialogare con avanti più bella che
abbiamo quella più prudente per
manifestarsi fragile figlia di
insicurezze figlia di un tempo che
fossero non dovrebbe nemmeno esistere
conoscete alejandro de rossi aveva
periodo costi un grandissimo artista di
leo
anzi non e marty st un poeta e un
regista un attore uno sceneggiatore
andare alla dunque un poliedrico qui
sostiene è ancora di due pick up parigi
dove legge in alloggi gratuitamente il
mercoledì pomeriggio a chi filma
nell'unico si dà una noi sostiene che
credo più poiché conferma rita siano
stati negli anni cinquanta e decidere
poi vi starete chiedendo per chiedere
anni 53 crescita perché in quel periodo
disse 53 giuliani poetico dell'umanità
pablo neruda linssen territorio gabriela
mistral parlo parlo de rocca e nino
carpa 35 quelli vissuti
contemporaneamente che dissero un nuovo
modo di fare così avevano deciso di
trasmettere un popolo cileno una nuova
mentalità da blenda è il più conosciuto
di tutti ma forse pochi sanno che può
prendere un passaggio molto esuberante
molto stravaganti ricerca di una casa a
forma di castello ed era così apprezzato
così a mano dal popolo che gli umbri
amici beni che la sbornia
facciamo e decantare le sue questi e
tutti avevano un solo desiderio
diventare poeti come paolo net succede
su serie come canzoni testi bisogno in
italia di misura su select e me caso dei
rom
succede che mi stanco lo devi interline
umile dei capelli della mia ombra
succede che mi stanco di essere sin
embargo segnate rischioso a sostare o
non dare quindi ho portato eppure
sarebbe piacevole dai fasti da un notaio
comune deciso dal tar monte alla monica
con un 8 ed eureka o uscite una monaca
con un colpo di orecchie serie a livello
di parlarci con l'ufficio rent di
talento milito sa stamo niente più e
sarebbe bello andare per le strade con
un coltello verde e gridare fino a
morire differente paolo de luca
forse la più stravagante e forte di
pablo neruda organizzava la tentata
canali gc truffe e risultava le persone
per strada e sono incontrate tra le
strade di santiago del cile
potevate imbattervi in lui che capitale
dei clan aprile su diversi cruciale non
siate capitanata tunisia
scegliete un materiale che qualunque
come si scelgono le stelle tra in ombre
di 235 migranti del money e io non ho
spingeva al suo amico eric erin si
trovavano a vivere in quella terra e che
ci sono di fare qualcosa di
importantissimo di farsi carico sia non
fosse chiuso decantata ma diventasse
poesia vissuto
io do rossi viso in pratica quindi
quello che è ma li metti poi anno prima
aveva insegnato il fondatore del
futurismo italiano da cui si deve essere
azione da così al terzo interessa e
allora io dopo insieme addetti che film
altro grande qualità allievo di parra
iniziarono a camminare diritti camminare
diritti significati cambiate mai
direzioni non in senso figurato in senso
reale e quindi quando incontrava di una
macchina state parecchie di sulla ma
quando incrocia la mantero si cavalca
val tanaro si arrampicano fino a cadere
kick ass bruciarsi le ginocchia e quanti
incontrava in vacanza anzi che
immaginate di solanto bussavano si
facevano aprile entravano e uscivano
dalle reti wi fi la rete chiede che le
persone che li abitano cosa pensavano la
rideva perché vivevano inebriati dalla
turistica di quel periodo da lucia
quindi e iperbole lagostina che
necessariamente di pecore ed è stupendo
pensare che in quel periodo in cile
se cantare i sanniti che ha vissuto che
in questa intensità e sono sicuro che
ciascuno di noi quando ho ascoltato il
racconto di metodo di deroga o di de
rossi ha immaginato un solista note di
avere il coraggio l'autore di essere il
compagno divenendo la compagna inerente
degli os che per libere per questi
momenti così unici e irripetibili
la questione non è statica ma questione
non è immaginazione la cristiana è
innanzitutto un ace ma così va vissuta
non è per caso stupefacente sorridere
non è per caso un magnifico avere il
coraggio di fare
ditemi che non siamo poetico riuscire a
vivere
senza timore compie tanti poetici
significa avere il coraggio di seguire i
propri desideri significava non è
popolare il mondo della nostra vita di
chi necessiti anche insensati
mantieni di perdersi bellezza quasi il
mal di testa
la crisi ad esempio bellezza allora
provate chiudere gli occhi e di te la
devi mangiare chiudendo gli occhi se le
parole di questa poesia seppur che
dolore non siano colme di bellezza ti
prego chiudete tutti gli occhi l'etna
verde si intende come seta sugli alberi
crescono le foglie rosse nemmeno
parlarne non fai ritorno tu torni solo
quando il profumo è sparito
avete mai pensato che ceca è bello è
anche vero avete mai inventata pc che
non certamente bello ci trasmette un
senso di decadenza di sincerità ci
rassicura anche padrone quando parla del
suo concerto di eros bisogna che
cercheranno troverà anche non è vero e
ciò che alcune vero era anche bello
calosi gratis ma allora volendo
scomodare anche a rispondere se la
poesia e bellezza è l'america merita la
verità di bellezza allora la poesia è
anche verità anzi qui
viene dal button e la verità che come la
poesia e la maggior parte della gente
odia maledettamente la questione da dove
sei tutto questo è un flusso continuo di
concetti che pervade ogni nostro singolo
respiro
aveva ragione perché risponde quando
ormai cieco bene invitato
nell'università di harvard per tenere
una conferenza sul significato della
questione del 1967 per 1968 in diverse
occasioni nella prima di essa
lui disse cut price su wii points in the
live action is metodo poi andiamo
personalità abbiamo perso come si sa ma
la ditta ne sono sicuro è fatto di
poesia e io mi voglio che tra le verdi
voglio avvertire uscire dalla crisi
significa rivivere e io non voglio
vivere una vita che non sia tale
a meno che lo sia solamente necessario
volevo vivere profondamente sociale
tutto il minimo di essa diventerete
akros pantano tanto da distruggere tutto
ciò che non fosse rita falciare ampio
per la sua terra fino a mettere la vita
in un angolo rivolta ai termini più
semplice visione emozioni azione
bellezza e verità
cos'è tutto questo sarà un amore
la poesia è piena di amore l'amore di
chi amore che viene provato l'amore che
mi ha ricevuto lauree che distrugge
quello che fa male la poesia è sempre
stato il pezzo normale per comunicare
l'amore ma tale cia correa lavori
calorie e cagionevole può essere le c'è
un filo di paglia che di forza non c'è
lo hobbit antico naturali capisca facile
credo che lo devono essere stato sincero
un po perché gli aumenti né ho preso in
giro io turlupinati ho messo in
particolare importante labbra mangiate
dal sorriso e l'altro macchiate dal
sorriso cosce
a volte le trombe mani di roccia nell ed
occhi tristi e solitari modo partiti
lenti e ritmati sento cicatrici ma al
filate rido comunque ghiacci una fuga
un abbraccio fiducia una parola
conosciuta che resta incerto che la
oscura saltano fuori di me non volute
ciò che faremo un castello di leggo ha
meno parole carenze e amore lettere
confuse con cui costruire diritt oggi il
configura le ferite cavolo che riesce
tutto il mio voto perché la poesia è
anche dolore
[Applauso]